so
he's doing jab cross combination okay
and one in
faster
not
that's why it's dynamic we're off the
bags
but it's a precursor to more life
you have to adjust to my body okay
so the body is the back
don't do the pushing more show some
percussion
don't break my wrists
and pick your shots so you have you can
hit the liver
you can hit the floating ribs uh
don't just aim for nothing
so you can see how narrow your face is
okay
so i'm gonna go one two
one two like a little slow mountain one
two so aim under my armpit one
two there you go one two three
is where i want to hit so instead of one
two and then i take a long time i'm
looking for that
that's where i want to hit one
two not this pause you see that pause
i'm looking for that one two boom
my body is rolling body
so don't get too narrow keep your width
boom body hits boom on the body
okay let's go okay one
two boom this
go ahead i'm gonna drop this and go
ride that strike
i'm not going to
brace there's an absorption
boom here absorb in there
then around tile
so
then wash his leg home
home through in this
um
[Music]
my head my arm my hand
don't stay out here smother
clap
make sure you have that
don't have any part of your body out
smother okay
let's go i hear my my drill
oh become thin and we want to breathe
and that's what sets up that struggle if
he's bigger stronger than me
i'm gonna lose that okay
[Music]
i'm not gonna but i'm not deviating
like you might think okay
it's the same thing as as he's pushing
i'm letting him move me
[Music]
so i'm organized a certain way it's the
same way
that i was already staying there it's
the same way the same
ground vectoring that's happening on the
strike
so i can project
it's the same thing so he comes around
he hits it my body moves within
moving me
i mean you're gonna hold it longer and
you'll see that he kind of moves the
whole of me
okay
harder drive
[Music]
i don't get that a-frame oh
not like this
and look for the sushi
so um
down this up
okay so use here's what you're
what he's touching so go
okay trap okay
so on this side i have this
and my shoulder okay so
that's what it's gonna go low
on this side he has that and that's what
goes
up keep it tight because you don't want
me to hit you okay
that's what goes up so
down up
is pokemon
you see down up
okay there's up down
he pushes he's going in
i start the rotation boom
[Music]
instead relax when you feel him go
push
you can't tighten it at all
[Music]
attack right did you feel it so as he's
going down boom i'm snapping it
right yeah okay boom
good boom right here
right there snap
[Music]
his arm but i'm not going
like this anymore